don't be scared brian i'm not scared
whoops written my job before we start
before we talk about before do we want
to address that you like 80 years old
well or should we just well because this
is hd okay here's a couple problems do
we want to i ate i ate a huge
you always blame it on your face salmon
curry i'm sure i tried cereal and pizza
yeah
and i didn't get a lot of sleep yep so
what happens is the old face gets all
tight if it's not
your tight face no i wish i was gonna
hold it no
hold it this is my natural if you want
to see if i relax my face all [ __ ]
aside
i mean really i'm ready i'm ready
okay it's just father time's okay
that happens fast yup you don't know
no you hold your face really well not
bad yeah you hold it really well
there you go look at that now hold on
hey give him give it a minute
not that area don't touch the gobbler
now here here's the thing
first of all before we get started and i
want to get started yeah i want to get
started i'm glad you're here but i have
a sensitive
eye to the male form did you see
chin go to my instagram as you guys know
how my [ __ ] instagram my ten percent
gator
did you know it was raining in woodland
hills
heavy droplets can i get under your can
i get under your arms if you want it
daddy
you've earned it i i know all the [ __ ]
you've been through no no you've hurt
and i'm getting wet now now here's the
thing though
i'm i'm i've got i gotta detect his eye
see and a lot of guys look at that let
me see
now those who's that guy
who's
he knows this he goes just here for the
800 stephen tyler comments
he's great he's great i like him for
that comment i know he's easily
wrong his body's he's bodybuilding
that hair should have his own podcast
and it's on its own tv channel
congratulations
that's his hair you got to see him go to
his page oh it's amazing well it's
amazing well
[Laughter]
hey when you posted when you posted that
video i started that me talking [ __ ] to
you about me benching
oh my gosh and some guy go some juice
head goes is that supposed to be
impressive
mark gets on and goes hey man from when
juice had another weird mess
from one juice had another weird flax
dude these numbers are good either way
but yeah well didn't you do 475 for 10.
oh i can get this
i'm going to need all the restaurants
sends me a picture of him dead lifting
500 pounds like he's getting up in the
morning
like he's waking up in the morning she
goes like that i was like you know what
that was early in the morning
after we did a bunch of sets of 10 475
for ten
you're strong kid now you're tight
you're tight i wouldn't feel those
patches so are you no no no i i know
your body
right there you feel that daddy you're
tight yep now you're tired some body
weight not some body fat there's no fat
on you right
or something a little bit but a lot less
and here's the other thing i think is
very noticeable and interesting
your skin's a little bit tight you're a
little flushed
red little flush
i i got a question can you join our
workout group
without the question because you can
you've lost you haven't lost weight
i'm doing great no no you're great
you're doing great yeah you couldn't
even move me
i'm sure you've changed your diet and
you're lifting weights yeah we've we've
both stopped eating
bad food on the road too yeah the thing
is what you mean
the thing is for me yeah what is it
you're thinking sure you look very
fragile right now i
am yeah i am but i feel like you take
you right now like a kitkat
you could yep okay it's just when i see
that much of a difference
and the skin looks like a little hard
work dedication i think hard work i
think dedication okay
wait what are you calling it now i think
dedicated
diet yes and i think one more thing to
bring
gym membership i think gym membership
keep going i don't know what we're doing
here
whatever sorry i just sneezed
i have bad allergies too
that's why i thought you were him right
i'm looking directly at youtube so
mainly him right he's real body transfer
i don't know
i'd look like this i would never i've
looked like this no no
no yeah
is looking to tat around and your skin
looks rhino thick
it looks rhino thick you look like you
could
thorn
the thorns would break off your face
it's so thick now now would you look now
jeff novitskiy asked me a piss in a cup
would i be fighting this weekend
probably not probably not probably not
probably not i got to be honest with you
it's a good look yeah thank you
it's a good one you really think i am
too i'm impressed with
what's going on you look tight you look
you look
waist less soft in the middle you've
always been big
but the answer is yeah i do no but you
made me i also had my suspicions
you kissed my ass i don't even know
where to get that [ __ ] okay
yeah i'm just blessed you look good yeah
that's all i got i kind of grabbed you
and you're you're immovable
yeah exactly but bam bam over here
yeah no i'm the undertaker and you're
the weird
ball bear yeah you're the ball bear well
what about that guy i want to pick
fights
oh what about fighter on the twink that
would be our wrestling name fire in the
twinkling fighter and the twink is good
now this might hurt a little kickboy
stick boy
i want to thank you guys for for asking
me to launch my new company's stick
that never happened get off that never
happened get off my nuts that never
guys thanks so much for the question
this is hurt maybe a tad i don't know
but you know how like we've been firing
the kid for i don't know eight years
yeah it's firing the cheerleader
and he's a cheerleader yeah i know d1
cheerleader i was
world champion i'm already steamed
because i was sitting in this mic
hey daddy daddy i was excited to sit
next to you
no no no i can't you know come on david
you know if this is the starship
enterprise it would have made it would
have made more sense because he's he's a
smaller guy you're a big guy
you're remarkable how long that's what
she said
how long has this new diet been going on
i mean
it's a thick boy summer it's a thick boy
summer
and you're i mean you've got definition
thanks buddy
i appreciate the hard work i'm glad when
people acknowledge my hard work
okay you getting your heart checked and
stuff we got to make sure that
toxicity he got he got his whole blood
check you got it all night no i do
not fish oil no i know
because you tend to overdo things too
you'll go no not anymore two tabs
i'll take four yep and then my big start
stopped working remember
remember dick was like hey cool body
we're going to shut down oh from the
trt yeah that was a nightmare when did
you start doing all these [ __ ]
secrets
i take yeah what do you think i get
nothing
i take nothing i take i i'm drinking
turmeric lemonade
but i i don't know you know what you
need to do you need to call your
boyfriend grill and go hey
what are you on give me some you need to
take frank grillo's
towel and drain it in your mouth after
he gets done working out he told me he's
natural
now even my boy plates more dates did a
whole thing on him not being natural
who's this place more dates more
dangerous the guy
that breaks down all the i'm going to go
through some names i want you to say
natty or or
or oh it's a fun game go all right um
are these all
uh famous hollywood people famous
hollywood people keep scrolling down you
see them
more plates more dates that's my guy can
we just go look at frank gorilla on this
thing uh
yeah you'll see it keep going down and
what if you keep this yeah
this guy's massive you'll see it it'll
be it's on there i don't see it
uh go to his videos yeah
how about just type it in bro all right
let me ask you this ready christian bale
for i mean for a certain role for batman
yes he wants 500 percent
i'm saying he's natty no no not on on
something
brad pitt uh troy oh absolutely not brad
pitt
i text him today i love him i said hey
you're probably on set in iran or
something
oh he did a whole thing yeah you wanna
watch a little bit of it
i'll tell you this frank frank say what
about he's got the greatest genetics
though
i agree like like you're seeing when
he's young when he's doing that gay uh
modeling dude
his picture when he's younger i saw
these pictures of him doing the calvin
klein [ __ ]
and like steve burns said he goes well
you look like you're wearing the batman
suit and he was that way when he was
you know that was that was and i like
what you're doing right now because he's
our friend but
but also let's play a game did a dick
touch his mouth or not when you're doing
that modeling stuff
you know what i'm saying oh he'll be the
first first of all nobody's straighter
than him but he'll be the first to tell
you look at that
oh damn some devil no handsome he's i'd
say he's even better
yeah what's he look like right now you
don't get better looking than frank
gorilla
he's on a cover of [ __ ] man what's he
look like right now like that right
there that's that's
right watchmen boss level you've seen
him a boss level no oh he's so
is that him right now that's him right
now yeah hey that's nice that's him
is it not frank is naturally a very
muscular guy hey that's not nettie
that's not neddy no one can do that hey
hey and i and i love you for this brian
because you're down for your friends
he's 55 years old oh he is name another
55 year old i've never seen anything go
in that body but food
thomas his body his body is a temple no
doubt
am i dripping for real but here's the
thing even on
[ __ ] his he's so disciplined oh yeah
like he's
like i'm telling anyone anyone who
thinks that
you just injection your ass and you look
like that you're out of your mind he
works
i'm telling even when i was fighting ufc
i'd be at the gym he'd be at the gym too
he outworked me that he was probably
47. the way he eats the way i've known
him 25 years not the way he is
the way it works out he'll work out he
he's up at five in the morning first
one few people i lived with him for four
months the only person i've ever seen
who
truly only needs five hours that's a
little sad when you guys like i've never
seen it yeah yeah
it was ridiculous but i've never seen
two girls two divorcees
rooming together we both have i thought
this was when you were younger
shitty shitty [ __ ] sofa yeah yeah
like one drink on the couch yeah it was
the outcome we
got kicked out of our house so we're
both like i guess hey brittany you want
to be here
let's live together but but um but
there is there is no one he's so [ __ ]
disciplined no
crazy the guy waiting so talented too
that's the other thing
how tall is he is he he's five yeah but
you mix his discipline with his talent
that's why he makes all that money for
netflix you know eight-figure deal with
netflix to make movies for them yeah and
he produces it writes it like he's a
beast
shout out to frank gorilla [ __ ] yeah
matt frank no i've never met frank
i actually know i think i met him once
like super quick
watch his backstage at the store will
sasso's in it boston yeah will sasso
gibson who's that earlier it just came
out the rock
just kidding when the rock watched it it
came out when the rock watched he said
hollywood has a new a new action hero
and it's micro that's from drock who's
gonna be our president
rock 2024 rock 2024. now that's a
natural the rock right
okay i have an important one the the
actor who was in
uh he's big blonde guy um chris
hemsworth yes
he's tough right because he's supposed
to oh no he's doing the whole hogan
uh on netflix you ever seen have you
seen him pushing the tire
no yeah it's what
he's so big yeah but i saw again i saw
him in the gym and [ __ ] dude talk about
a guy works his ass off yeah
beast well you know it's the best cardio
i've ever seen out of any athlete i know
you're going to say
travis barker really you knew he was
going to say that
or you were hoping he wasn't i've told
brian before because you know he's
always on the drums yeah yeah so this oh
yeah he talks about
oh dude he like you know i'll do like
you know five five minute rounds with a
minute rest
yeah he just does 45 minutes straight
he's he's like jesus christ dude
wow and he's just like he goes through
that box and you know he doesn't do
that's crazy
yeah because he's thinking how long he
drums during the performance right he's
going upside down and all that [ __ ]
damn vegan yeah he is he's all natural
he's on that he's powered by plants
speaking of boxing i can't wait for
canelo billy joe saunders this saturday
dawg that's going to be a
i've been calling it forever i was like
billy joe saunders matches up the best i
talked to wayne mcculloch
and he goes in historic sound i guess i
think i'll do okay for a while
and then connect harry can i go to the
body drop him he'll go to the body
i had to hit him in the body i know i
don't know wait so you got canelo
yeah he to me is the best one ever never
bad against but you think this is a good
matchup for him
yeah as far as like the most challenging
matchup you can make in a long time
if he's gonna lose it would be to billy
joe saunders yeah he's a beast a lot of
people don't know who he is billy's a
monster
yeah matches up well i know who canelo
is though now uh logan paul
uh floyd mayweather's fighting your boy
may or might not be on the desk for that
fight
is that right we'll see you should be on
the desk we'll see
but um yeah now are you a fan of this
like you're a fan of like jake paul on
that stuff
i'd like to see jay paul fight a boxer
it's like a
real boxer just that guy who would have
had some experience what about mike
what about what about mike perry ufc
fighter known for his knockout power
no grappling story but why why did he
keep going ufc fighters i i kept
thinking about kelvin gastelum i i think
calvin would
it'd be a bad day for jake because
calvin's maybe
you know boxing is different isn't it
it's just so different mid it's at that
mid level
the one thing i will give jake is he's
like in and logan for now but
especially jake is he he's at least
dedicated to him he works his ass off
when i saw him taking fighting boxing
real boxers and getting
almost knocked out taking real head
damage you got to respect that he's only
been boxing three years i know if you
talk to like other boxers like
the kid can [ __ ] he can hit you see
how hard he hits he looks like he hits
hard he's athletic
and he works he obviously i wasn't
hating on him because they're you know
friends of mine
but i was like yeah you know he'll
probably lose to been asking because
ben's been there some monsters and then
we were in miami i said something below
the belt
uh chappelle and i were in miami with
jay and we're in the lobby
and uriah faber was staying at the same
hotel and he's like chop i heard what
you said you and rogan breaking out jake
paul he's like i'm telling you dude
i'm with you like i want ben to win
because he's one of us we're he's alumni
but
have you seen jake's movement i go no
where would he post he is he posts on
his instagram like
no he's look show him i'm like oh [ __ ]
yes ben's in trouble dude
so here's your watches it wasn't like
as much as i tried to box yeah the one
thing i learned was
how how hard it is like i gained a real
respect for boxing
and so when you see real boxers if
they're hitting mids
there's always there's always a goal in
mind like you don't just hit mitch
randomly you're you're
you're you're working on patterns bop
bop you know your your your head's off
the center line all that stuff there's a
lot more to it yeah trainer doesn't have
you just hitting you're doing things
specifically
for a reason right okay and and i'm i'm
watching jake paul
pop up right and moving and i'm watching
and he's like he's
head movement and everything else and
i'm just like damn and then i see ben
asking i swear to god
all due respect dude he's got his
trainer meeting him halfway so his arms
are doing this bad habit
yeah he's going pop up papa like let the
way actors
well i told my boys that are at wild
card were like
oh ben came in for one day and then
stood freddy up he didn't even train
with him
yeah so he just i think ben was like
he's trying to make a lot of money and
it doesn't matter you know you don't
think he faked that knockout though no
no no you can't get fake no no that's
stupid no he got hit
yeah because the way he the way he goes
if you listen to john mccarthy he's like
he's like stupid you can't yeah because
he's like as a ref like we're
they they have the eye for where when
the brain shuts off like
so if now if brian tried pretending that
he got knocked out
there's certain movements that the
body's just naturally not going to do
and ben didn't do that natural movement
yeah the way his body is your brain shut
off so it's like the weight like when
you fall forward you're
natural you can put your hands out or do
something yeah he didn't even he didn't
even try to break like
at least at least like flinch before he
hit the ground like no i mean he just
boom yeah
i'd like to tell you who i wouldn't mind
seeing jake paul fight is mario lopez
who's been boxing he's he box i see him
at walmart get
hey you talking about ac slater yeah get
out i think he bucks
yeah yeah no no no no no no no he's no
doubt get out no i've seen him in
in wild cards yup get out both hey
just get up not ashamed i'm glad you
came thank you
jake would knock him out in 30 seconds
really it'd be easier than been asking
is that right
ac slater he's never been in a fight he
no he does a lot
he spars and all that stuff talk about
in the gym bring up mark i've seen it
the botox that guy he's
that's all he had daddy or not that's an
addie i think that i'll answer
no well no damn it hold on oh there it
is with canelo yeah and i
yeah yeah i bet i beat canelo's going
full blow
look at his body watch watch watch okay
well
no there's another video what
look at this trainer smiling look at his
fat trainer smiling
you know why because he's this is a
lying toying with an
old old mexican ac slater
he looks athletic to me man he looks
like he can throw bro
oh look at
i'm sorry not ben jake mario might beat
that
but jake would knock him out i don't
know i don't know
i mean i saw him in wild card he looked
like he was doing really good but
at the same time that's me judging i
know he's sparse i'd rather see you
versus mario lopez i think
that's what i mean i think no no are you
down to do that like
i mean we'll have you featured with
lamar odom and aaron carter
i'm getting dizzy like i feel a little
bit and he goes yeah you're boxing so
you're making any money i don't know
guys keep it up it's good for your
especially your age it's good for you
yeah what you do that's
perfect oh my [ __ ] getting caught in the
back of the head you're not seeing stars
it's too dangerous it's too dangerous
boxing is
no joke it's not jiu jitsu you can roll
around
you can't play boxing i guess what can
help
mario lopez you know what but no one's
getting real
even then you take hits even though
that's stupid something happens i know
what i want to address
on yesterday's podcast i mean chappelle
we're talking about uh osama bin laden
no we were talking about pagan would you
be down for that pegging i'm not into it
but i know
i i know a girl a boy never be in an
argument
with a with with a girl and a guy when
the argument is the end
where they're having the armageddon
argument and you're in the room you know
how they go
they start saying terrible things to
each other yeah yeah [ __ ] you
you bet yeah and you've smelled knew
that and you're trying to play [ __ ]
and just so you know never [ __ ] me but
loves to get pegged and walked out of
the room
is this a friend that we both have it's
your friend do i know the person
uh you don't okay but i went i went i
didn't hear anything
it's so loud i couldn't hear that i
acted like i was deaf i went
i can't hear
i know a very famous uh another famous
actor who likes to get pegged yeah
it's interesting and i know that forever
but it's not pagan we didn't get we got
emails on when i said
uh i was watching that history channel
thing because
yesterday was the anniversary of them
killing oh bin laden
or something no no no people are stupid
well what i said was
is they didn't have video this this like
you know in that when there's that
situation
situation room where they're all
watching hillary clinton you know
obama you know everyone's in the uh
situation room and they're all watching
people take that picture and think
they're watching the shooting of
osama bin laden i thought that they're
not they're not
in people's emails like yeah that's what
they were watching they weren't though
this is from obama's mouth so unless you
know something
obama doesn't know then then i believe
you guys but this from obama's mouth he
goes no
what we were watching there is there was
a drone hovering over
the house and so we saw the helicopters
land
we saw the helicopter crashed when we
saw the navy seals go in and then we're
watching that
we're watching from that side we didn't
have a live feed
on the inside we didn't they didn't see
osama get shot right
but they were seals some of the seals
they were watching them going in when
they actually they didn't
have a lot of they took pictures they
took pictures and but they took pictures
and then got on the mic with geronimo
drama drama meaning
they got him they got him and they
killed him right that's what they were
waiting on they didn't have a live feed
like
the navy seals had video but it wasn't a
live feed into that room
got it yeah that's like that people
saying yeah it is
i'm telling you from obama's mouth he's
like we didn't have a life feed into
that did you know you had a drone
i was there watching the buildings he's
part of navy team still sits
and you're welcome you're welcome for
your freedom thank you but
and and by the way
dude if i was a navy seal i'd be on so
much [ __ ] wouldn't you
i mean i don't know if you need it bubba
do they get tested or something i just
think that when you're walking for 12
miles with all that stuff on you might
want to be
you'd probably get thinner i don't know
though but there's stuff you could take
like you'd want to be
i'm sure a lot of those guys are doing
what they have to because you stay
injury and you're welcome for your
freedom yeah
i think if you're a special forces guy
and you're in the field like that you
should be allowed to do
all the drugs me too whatever it takes i
mean hitler gave the nazis [ __ ] math
that's how they march so fast they're
like how the [ __ ] are they going through
the night
um monofil that's what they use
monofilament pro vigil and all those
things yeah
it's like like adron [ __ ] steroids oh
so you just [ __ ] fly through the
night
damn you're welcome for your freedom
thank you appreciate
don't send us articles of them of these
random
nobodies saying no they were watching
the actual shooting and then trump
wanted to release the shooting video
and they wouldn't allow him to you want
to release it but
either way they have the footage of them
shooting obama but that wasn't allowed
into obama yeah that wasn't a live feed
into the president
they were watching a drone footage right
they had no idea what was going on they
heard gunfight
yeah no cause that's why i think i even
asked you that yesterday because that
picture like is
like i was like oh they must have been
watching it and their mouths are like
this yeah exactly because they're
watching
and they hear they're just watching like
all they're doing is watching them enter
yeah and they're like oh man and
everything
is working out and then they go toronto
drama they're like oh and they all start
celebrating
got it i met a gun there's video but it
wasn't a live feed into the situation
i was at a gun range i saw that video by
the way
you look great in des moines shout out
to des moines um
you saw him at that one and he saw him
at the world online
i just started doing steroids that's all
i'm talking about my cb live i'll be
there may 6th through the 9th i'm doing
a posing seminar
if you want to stand up i'll do that too
but she'll be live may 6th to the 9th
this
this thursday through thursday yeah
that's this thursday friday she's doing
sunday i never do that daddy needs
sunday
i'm just doing hey okay click on the one
for me for the click on the one here
get another tesla and the rock don't do
that that's not a tesla but don't do
that is that a test
that's attached oh no it's a prius how
to turn your car to your advantage when
you want to impress
passes by or enhance your dating life
even a plug-in white prius
not that sexy but watch this is there a
rule i can't hang out
like this in front of my favorite coffee
shop how about getting crazy
bring it up here there's no rule says i
can't be the cat of my own [ __ ]
[Laughter]
one of my personal favorites maybe i'm
stretching okay people go
that guy a dancer or is he into karate
okay dancer karate in my case it's both
if you've got a nice backside and you're
proud of it try this
why not i'm 54. you're in sweats too by
the way middle of the day and sweat
brian
so even though i got a white prius
doesn't mean i don't have a hell of a
back sock
i hope that helps guys thanks so much
did you see my other did you see when
the
one was
you're still doing the show with i see
sam comment you're still doing the uh
yeah i'm doing so conspiracy uh um
[ __ ]
social club theory social club we're
doing two
we're doing we've got patreon patreon
and rockfin
which is awesome rockford because they
don't because well rockfin is this
platform where you don't get censored at
all the problem with doing
social club i can't do it on youtube we
get we get banned yeah we can do on
patreon right
uh youtube owns patreon yeah but they
also they're just venmo
they usually use vimeo vimeo and then oh
no sorry patreon uses vimeo yeah and
vimeo will take you down a lot of times
because even
on a page yeah but that's what we want
i want crazy so sam sam goes crazy with
conspiracy theories and i debunked them
by the way i'm losing all the time
because i made up the show there's so
much they did he goes i got it i came up
with it
now what we're doing because it's gotten
really popular it's gotten thank you
yeah
it's gotten very popular on patreon and
now rock family
it's getting there we're taking we got
55 episodes i'm listening 55 episodes
we're going to take from episode 1 all
the way to 55 and release one just audio
on everywhere you can get podcasts
starting with the first one right so the
old one
the problem is we can't release it on
youtube because they're like you guys
what audio you can do so what happens
but on vimeo they take it down
a lot of times too they'll take it down
so we have to do we have it yeah but
that's why we go go to rafflin we have
to go to rothman because
no you can watch everything all right
that's insane dude
so you know like we'll talk about
pegging i'm sure this [ __ ] this when i
said when we talk about pegging or
what steroids that will alert youtube
and then i can't like if i want to put
money behind promote the show youtube
won't that's crazy like nope
it's worse than tv now it's like the
internet used to be the wild west but
what's
happening is there are there are
platforms now that are moving that are
realize this
and and things like rockfin which a lot
of people are going to
which is why i well spotify video
unless you're alex jones all right
spotify is pretty loosey-goosey right
june as far as i know so far
but if they barely started doing videos
right you do ads on tick-tock if you do
ads on
facebook or whatever yeah if you have i
know if you even bleep
your bad words the algorithm catches it
and then you can get demonetized and
trying to get it back as a
[ __ ] and then you get a check mark on
your page yes man and you get three
check marks they literally like
you know we've had this page for eight
years they would really just wipe it
that's a disaster take it out that's
take off the episode
no the entire page yeah we'll shut your
[ __ ] down really yes and that's a
disaster but like
you're the person that you're debunking
things you're not listening to
sam's all for it though same beliefs
that's what's great about him
sam will be like the problem you're one
of my favorite one
the ice cube one where he was like ice
cube is a fbi informant that started
getting
it right no he's wrong i'm gonna say the
power he's right no
no the podcast is [ __ ] oh well
no i'll tell you well you know about
hillary clinton being uh
a lizard what the [ __ ] are you talking
about here's the problem with that with
the computer so sam sam cracks me up
the reason it's great it's so much fun
it's because sam's so [ __ ] hilarious
yeah sam's he's also hilarious like a
lot of times we do the podcast and it's
just
i'm like let's just [ __ ] yeah
because because sam will be like well
hillary clinton worships satan and
drinks baby blood
and shows queen elizabeth i'm like what
and oh hitler was a roth child and still
alive do you have any evidence of this
well i would there's you can't go you
can't but
youtube doesn't that was bought up yeah
so if you bring out like you know
google's bought by the you know the
leads and the
i go crazy also when you try to google
yeah he's like of course you're not
gonna find it because well then
how do you get elite's own google clock
here
theory on all of it okay all right let's
lay down duckduckgo yeah it's stuck.go
right brian yes
but i have a theory on all this it's
really we have we have magaville
we have wolkville yeah right we have the
woke we have the maggot
we have most of us trying to get to work
in the middle
kind of like i'd say 90 yeah but then
but you also have the conspiracy theory
people
yeah and and most people have lost their
faith in mainstream media
most or a lot of people but then there's
a lot of people that like at swear by
cnn
or swear by fox okay i would say that's
woke versus
they call those people sheeple yeah but
but this really is
but it's really interesting to see how
how this woke thing this crazy cancel
culture
awoke thing that's really sensitive it's
mostly young people under 30.
it's it's it is a religion it is a form
of religion
yeah it's think about it church
questions you were saying woke is the
formula yeah the church used to
practice exorcisms they would get the
demon out of you or they would say
you're a witch you own cats you talk to
yourself you have to be burned
or drowned or they would excommunicate
you it's exactly
what the woke community does but go on
that like at the
ex communicate you from the village
which is basically like cancel you from
social media platforms exactly so we
can't kick you out of the village now so
what we're going to do
is take away your voice on social media
and youtube and your ability to make the
same thing is
kicking another village and you can't
make a living so you have to go over
there and you don't get to be part of
anything
right and that's what that is why are
you grabbing i'm making this
i'm listening dude get your avatar or
avatar whatever hand is whatever you're
um
[Laughter]
you look like an avatar of your your old
self all tight
and purple what were you saying right
i don't even know anymore because i felt
so good
but i got confused you're saying it's a
modern day witch hunt it is it's it's
it's people want to feel pure people who
want to feel like they can purify
society create a utopia no racism break
down all the lines
that's not not right we were talking
about the last time with christie he
goes you know how insane the world would
be
if we there's no racism like he's like
what would they do
like if everything was there was a race
already yeah everything's fair like
chris what would we do no but also
here's my joke and but this is true
you can say anything you want about
communism you want to make everything
equal the problem is there are only so
many seats in the front of the [ __ ]
plane
life if life's a cow you're going to run
out of steak then you get the hamburger
then you get some sausage
somebody's going to be holding the lips
in the [ __ ] at the end of the day
you know nobody wants to eat that and
nobody wants to chew that heart and i'll
eat it yes
but that's what happens as long as
you'll eat right
yeah of course you now you're missing
the point man oh yeah i think
we're talking about the cow oh yeah yeah
i saw where you were going as long as
you have good [ __ ] and bad [ __ ] as long
as there's
a better view the people that know how
to game the system are going to get the
better view whether that's capitalism or
communism has never been different
you're not going to cr you're not going
to create equality
by enforcing you know a central body to
make everything equal
you know who i find impossibly hot
candace owens
i wonder what that is dinner podcast
just embossed ladies
she's beautiful and smart outer right
hot yes smoke you never seen canna
stones
really or you have or no yeah i don't
know what that face is
you don't think she's attractive she's
so smart too
i'm gonna say her husband is a blonde
he's a blonde
the first time you ever said no i know
that's absolutely i'm shocked
gross what where's the blonde and blue
hey you look great there i'm a good
looking kid did you die
what did you do to the beard and the
hair there no i didn't dye it it looked
good maybe it's a filter
no short hair that's a filter is that
all is that natty
that's natty i'm just uh i look like
you've got yourself a little bit looking
exactly like a 54 year old man that's
yeah there you go like
how old is candace 30 something 31 32
no she's young she's younger than me
she's young you know what i'm too dumb
for her she's very smart i know i'm too
dumb she's constantly teaching me [ __ ]
she loves to laugh though i had her
laughing
i know a lot of people look into your
show she's 32.
yeah her man is just he's a smart lad
her man is a very handsome guy long
blonde hair from britain
and speaks of course the queen's you
know what absolutely i bet it sounds
better i bet it sounds better dating her
than it actually is it might be a
nightmare
um oh he's okay i don't know she seemed
like he's an elephant
he's a la4 yeah he's at la-4 uh he
looked good in person really
yeah he looks like [ __ ] there and he's
just
humble but he has no problem taking a
back seat he's humble
like he kind of supports her and helps
her out well you could well yeah you
have to
she's a boss dude you're not gonna you
know what i'm saying no
like if they're walking down an alley
he's [ __ ] snuggling up to her 100
but i think he comes from like british
dude he's a lord oh i didn't tell you
i'm a lord oh yeah you got to call him
lord
brendan now yeah i didn't tell you i'm a
lord i own land in uh england i did not
know that some fan in england bought it
for me
so i'm lord brendan they bought yeah no
this guy
he came up and it was he was in naples
yeah
you said some fan in england i thought
he was from england no no no no
no he was not he was american oh he just
bought it in yeah he brought either way
i'm a lord
anyway he's he's certified lord call me
lord come on man come on dude
don't make me beat you i haven't seen
you in a while hey i'm sorry yeah you've
been threatening me with violence
via text he just says i could kill you
me very easily
bare hands randomly how do you respond
to that
i got it random did i know you put go to
social media chin you post on social oh
that's right
people think we're serious we do yeah
hey everybody
hey everybody talk every day leave this
brian i've never been stronger i did 3
15 10 times 335 by 6
then 225 you bench 225 22 times i could
kill you i
so easy right now kill bare hands you
whenever i want
i like how you just you don't even
remember so i gotta kill he didn't
respond
bare hands didn't respond you didn't
respond whenever i want and then finally
goes
dude i know yeah john annick you loaded
him up love it
what'd they call him oh john hannick
though
mark carly's on there true so i'm
hitting i have a question yes
your boy from poland tall young
no the guy who knocked down checked out
sorry
who knocked out the best looking women
in the world
i heard croatia yeah russia
russia well croatia kind of all the same
like
croatia and the czech republic have i
been there
no i'm going to say this though prague
best looking women on the planet
you're talking about my boy yuri now now
now this guy now here's my
can i make a i want to say one thing
about it i want to see if you agree very
impressed
your finger has all the wrinkles sir
oh my god dude
look man time bro
hey andrew
you know we're leaving the studio as
well and i'm not going to send you that
dress
hey guys sagebrush you come in here
there's
just blank walls i know like what do you
say about yuri though
yuri knocked out dominic reyes he's
creative he's a badass he's a stud
world champion here's the thing he's a
world champion he's a world champion
kickboxing k-1
mma yes yeah one championship world
champion yes
or ryzen sorry ryzen okay here's the
thing ryzen not one championship he gets
hit though
he does get hit that's and i thought to
myself you get it it's alarming
it's alarming reyes hits hard too though
and he died shots didn't he
and vulcan also landed on that worries
me too it worries me too because
he's unorthodox he does that stuff but
you want to bet right now
that he beats john and he'll be an
underdog
i don't know his wrestling what is his
wrestling and submission game well i
mean i i don't think it's great
reyes took him down okay and dominic i
mean jan will double leg the [ __ ] out of
allah izzy yeah or no no no no okay
he's way bigger he's a lot bigger he's
huge dude he does team yeah you want to
be he's my favorite fighter right now
you want a bet
that's bet on the show i can't bet
against i think he's better
no take on no i see i think john's the
worst matchup john hits hard man i know
that i'm gonna i'm gonna get on it so
let's just bet on it here's here's what
i'm gonna bet on
if he fights yawn he bites you on
kendall
[Laughter]
daddy's doing sunday you know it's funny
when he said thousand dollars
i was like i was like i'm gonna say yes
but i'm not gonna pay him
all right we'll do a thousand you're
probably do a hundred dollars
and if he beats john and he fights jon
jones if john comes down to
205 he will get his thing back he won't
beat john
uh john's a different story john that
light heavyweight it's not even a
conversation anymore he's put on so much
weight for him to go back down to like
heaven
yeah he's huge so he's on 60 he's huge
but he's a big guy anyway so he's
usually watching
like 230 240. but the thing is about
john is uh
he you know he only has a few fights
left he's going to get paid and fight at
heavyweight
but the only way john come down to light
heavyweight is if yon goes on like this
10 fight like
winning streak and just they're like oh
he's the greatest lightweight ever
heavyweight ever yeah then john's go
really i'm going to go back down and
beat the [ __ ] out of you that's what's
going to happen yeah like someone would
have to go on something
about the thing about giannis and and
not taking he's 205 but he did lose a
lot
early on yeah and i was never i i'll be
i've never been that sold on him and i
think yuri
does beat him but i'm i'm curious to
your point if yuri were to land on him
with that power
like what happened because you know john
hits so hard i was going to say if y'all
you're i noticed he got hit a lot and if
yon sits down but you know what you're
interested about yarry
and he did get wobbly wobbles but he's
got wobble here's the thing about yuri
not a scratch on his face no swelling
nothing i know
i know and here's the other thing first
team all body too he also
yes all body that body won't quit
that body won't quit how much how much
my car and this how much to wash my car
and and the hair yeah
i love that now did he repost me today
yeah he did dude
he did yeah you said great things about
him yeah i love him well he's he's the
most
most entertaining fighter he's a giant
tony ferguson he's
he's just like tony ferguson he's a lot
of fun
to watch um i his chin's insane dude but
he got wobble
how long will that change and that's the
thing john is going to jan will hit him
if he's not careful now here's the thing
though you say he didn't have any
kids but he's very he's very good at
this he's he's rolling shots
he's still like when you get he's just
at the edge of the pocket he's not
taking photos
this is why i ride with him now remember
too he's had offers to sign with ufc
before and he went no no let me
get the experience on my belt this is so
smart i wish i did this he goes let me
get the experience on my belt fighting
over here at ryzen
and then once i'm ready i wanna come to
ufc and contend right away
that's my game smart so he has like 35
i don't know he has like 30 fights and
then went to the ufc find out how old he
is
and he's had two fights now he's
fighting for a world title like that's
the way it should be done yeah
he's born 1992 by the way all right so
he's 30.
28 28. 28. dude that's young
that's very yeah he's not even his prime
yet dude and jan is 45
no jan is older john's older yeah john's
been in there for a while
i just i just like his movement over
yawns man but everyone's
if every bit of 38. okay so that's
that's
listen all due respect this time it
might be time for the new lion to come
in
it's not taking nothing away from beyond
these lines from the czech republic
not only those lions live out there they
don't they don't but they
didn't yeah and they're in zoos and i'm
sure there's a couple of zoos in the
czech republic
i mean there is a eurasian lion i
suppose yeah i guess it's part of the
eurasian land now he's a [ __ ] you
think so
technically i guess he could wander down
from somewhere he's a stud though you
would know though he's a stud
yeah he's a stud um
they're a couple the most impressive
fighter to me in a weird way is
pietry young i just got on that train
after the out because i thought sterling
would be a nightmare match up for him
and after watching i'm like oh [ __ ] he's
doing whatever he wants to sterling
and now they got a rematch i know
sterling had surgery too
yeah and you see the nate diaz fight
fell off you see that jen yeah it
sucks injury but they just jump pushed
it to june
which is a problem or something like
that i'm hoping the canelo uh
saunders that's why it's happening
because they're talking about ring
problems no that's happening all right
that's happening now does daddy want to
go to miami with me if i do do the
logan paul fight i do you what is that i
feed him june 6. now you fit in miami
now logan paul is doing his camp
dominican republic so i'm gonna have to
go there
you you should have your old friend
brian callum with you yep you got to
carry my bag though
you got to earn your keys like this with
locked knees and waiting
but i want you in a suit in a suit so
hot it's
so hot it's miami and you allow me one
napkin
and i hire someone else and i'm super
mean to him wear me off
dude hey hey you know chappelle's never
been to miami so we did miami improv and
you know
jay jay's not been there either he's
such a tourist he's like let's walk down
south beach
so we [ __ ] oh man we're we we we we
can't it's aggressive we can look more
l.a
we're all in jeans i was in sweatpants
yeah
i think best looking women in the world
sir everyone has asses
everyone well let me say it again been
alive that's what
that's my favorite city in florida the
best [ __ ] women in the world i like
naples
i gotta go i gotta go with my april's is
my favorite city you know i had a more
my vibe i know it's
it's classy a lot of money not unlike
not uncommon to see a
60 million dollar house no well you know
you know it's the richest
in fl i didn't know how wealthy it was
then and you know they have
hands down no lie i think it's the
rev where's the car shot is it called
rev oh the uh that porsche you have the
number one car collection most valuable
car collection in north america there
yeah so when you sent me your boys cars
this this car shop it's like jay leno
leaves his cars there
adam corolla i thought i was hitting
that so so the guy took us around and i
go uh
how much is that car and he goes ah we
got an offer for 30 million and the
owner turned it down
and i go that one he goes there's only
one in the world this is the first
lamborghini
ever and then he had another one that
was in le mans and it was it was
only one of one you know how much is
that he goes you keep asking me this man
he was
priceless he's like literally priceless
they offered no someone offered them 100
them 100 mil for one
of them i don't remember which one it
was yeah i go to this house in the
beverly hills and i was at a dinner
and i sit in a car and i sent him at the
video i just sit in it
right there yeah jay forces to go there
rev institute
yeah pedro i said the car i said i
thought it was worth about eight hundred
thousand dollars
no no and brennan goes that's worth 20
mil easy
easy at least at least and the guy
drives it to get coffee and drives it
around
it's nuts like those cars were nuts but
that's the kind of car you you wouldn't
like that car
because i would you would i would but
would you drive it
oh yeah you'd drive that one's sick
because if i could afford it who gives a
[ __ ] but you just
what is it about that that you get it's
just like i like stuff other people
don't have
like my gt2 rs other like not many
people a few other people have them but
they don't have it tuned in so it's your
competitive nature
uh it's not even that i just don't want
what everyone else has yeah
you know like i don't want a tesla now
because now tesla's becoming the new
[ __ ] prettiest yeah
like everyone has one yeah i don't want
the standard career because
all agents and ca have them my lease is
up soon i might get a different car
but i don't know what are you thinking
nothing getting another tesla i don't
think so but
you're not into fast cars no i like
teslas because they're they get quick
they're so easy they have that plaid
edition it was like 016 like i don't
know [ __ ]
this car is already fast enough yeah but
i'm just lazy no no gas
just and no no lag and i don't turn it
off
get in get out safe as [ __ ] boom really
fast yeah i remember brian was one of
the first ones to tesla i'm like this
thing has the automatic drivers like
sure does when we're going down a bray
or something yeah he puts it on
it's all fun oh my god dude
and i finally forgot how to do the
manual you know the automatic drive-in
so i click on telling something i go
we're going like 90 miles down the
highway down that you remember that
we're going
right remember we're in the tesla suv oh
no you didn't you didn't come there that
was uh palm beach
that was tampa oh it's tampa yeah i
wasn't like you right there so we're in
tampa
and damn i get the tesla suv i've never
driven one i want to see what it's like
so we
use that app toro so i get the tesla suv
and i figured it out means you were
trying to figure out finally figured out
we were like 90 down like that skinny
highway that's
over the water i just click it i take my
hands off no one noticed i'm like oh
[ __ ] it's driving itself
so i was trying to go you got guys the
thing is about this
oh i'm like the end of just doing it
yeah man i was like this is sick
here's the problem though lex friedman
who designed all of it for tesla
yeah lex friedman is the is the guy who
designed it at mit he's an mit professor
black belt judo and jiu jitsu
and uh he designed it he basically he's
the guy the brains who was like do this
this
and on rogan rogan goes so if it um and
he goes not if
when it malfunctions when that's trouble
keep your hands on the wheel
that's from the guy who designed it and
i went oh well you hear about people
dying
pretty frequently but then also i'll
also see guys in la
snoring going down the highway straight
of sleep
yes that's a lot of scary do you see
elon musk who's hosting saturday live
this weekend but she elon musk
talking about mars he's like yeah a lot
of people are going to die man
everyone gets old but he's like i mean
dude what we're trying to do who knows a
lot of [ __ ] happened a lot people
everyone's like he's so insensitive like
he's like he's no you gotta crack a few
eggs and make an omelette man
you guys want to get to mars some
[ __ ] [ __ ] are gonna die man a lot
of smart people are gonna die
yeah he's cuz you're not sending just
joe schmoe up no like some of the most
brilliant minds would be on those first
[ __ ] jets i don't want a [ __ ]
going on
if you're on conspiracy social club you
wouldn't have gotten to the first
sentence because
oh flatters start talking about no i'm
going to be sam start talking about
start talking about elon musk
well elon musk
they're right about that because we did
take the german nazis
their smartest rocket scientists
yeah but also division also not that's
not the scientists and nasa are
not anymore no not no they're gone they
died because
they were 40 when we took it because
that was in the 40s so they would be
that's amazing i did a podcast
on conspiracy social club where i had a
flat earther
he was so ready he was so prepared like
he
actually believes and i go but where is
the
he goes well there's a rim of ice around
and that's why nobody's been there i go
what's beyond it he goes
we don't know i was like why wouldn't
you just fly because i don't know
so all the pilots are in on it too every
pilot oh that's what i said i go so when
you do a flight plan you're taking
account bring uh realizes the earth
isn't flat
the guy he he saw you he showed him last
night no i told him about last time he
was trying to bring it
he was trying to prove his point that
earth is flat when the sun comes up and
it goes up and down
and there's supposed to be no curve and
there's a curve and he goes ah [ __ ] by
the way
rogan is not uh i mean i'm sorry um
what's his name no sam tripley is not a
flat earther he's not a photographer oh
he's not no
but there are guys i think eddie spears
eddie's
conspiracy some of my favorite people
are flat earthers
like i love eddie i love sam yeah sam's
fighters and sam's not flattering he's
you know he's
he's touching the line of flat earth it
was on world star
yeah i'm not seeing it it's it's
been it's been uh it was put to rest
you're in uh
you're in uh nashville a lot aren't we
i'm doing nashville
may 19th you're always back you're
always out
because i do the so i so me and steve
byrne and steve lives there
yes why don't you link up with josh
wolfe he lives there i do
we the last live podcast we did was with
josh wolfe
and we did one with nate barghotzi who
was great how funny he's now
he's so funny he's so funny we're doing
it's a live podcast we do this live
podcast
i've seen the clip yeah may 19th by the
way uh sandy's get your ticks
but we we do this live podcast and
barakatsky shows up barkotsky can
nate can just literally i'm pulling
rabbits out of a hat and doing whatever
i can they can say
like three words in a monotone word and
destroys
he's just like i don't know i don't
really have the nicest guys on the phone
he only did 30 minutes for his special
right the netflix one
longer than he do 30 with netflix i
thought it was the third he did it
during the pandemic
yeah he said he said on the podcast he
said i went on stage and usually
after the first one they're like you got
it just do another one for safety
and they they all had massive threw him
off you know he just couldn't hear him
laughing
yeah i think i'm doing terrible and so
he gets he comes back on they go we
definitely didn't get it the first time
we definitely did not get it
you got to get it the second time oh i
lied i lied
one hour yeah they've only done a few 30
minute specials
yeah oh that's oh no he does have a 30
minute on there it's
it's an older one it was with the the
degenerates i think
he's a great guy man i love the guy he's
great i love
nate he's one of my favorite people in
comedy yep how about uh
new york announced that they're opening
up may 15th
or like theater everything they're open
everything 100
full capacity let's go new york what i
sent that to schultz i went get tough
i'm so sick of your miami ass back to
new york
he goes we going baby and posted the
date oh that's great
i was like yeah opening two and he goes
nope he's doing miami proper
and and and that hilarious uh
underwear ad was just like the most
expensive underwear did you see it
his ad yeah and i didn't see it oh he
did a video with jelly roll about
opening up oh my he did he did uh
he did a a video a commercial for
uh for undies or something yeah like
it's a new underwriting
this is the most expensive underwear i'd
watch this [ __ ] it's the most expensive
on a rod
beasty there's a few guys that are blown
up during this pandemic
kim tim dillon and uh santino
they're just like you just you just see
like this explosion of all these guys
yeah
well korean like everyone has their
funny everyone has their moment right
and theirs is like
just right yeah all monsters yeah all
monsters been at it a long time just
keep doing the work
yeah we're in austin how was that
what do you think so let me get your
honest take on where everybody let me
ask you would you
well a lot of you know obviously theo
bought a house in nashville and he
fights back every three weeks
but you know field goes man this place
is small man i'm like
yeah dude it's nashville like it's it's
a
you know there's kind of i guess when
you visit it feels like this big city
vibe but once you're there like think
about it dude like
compared to l.a like you're used to la
daddy
look la has a lot of problems but as a
lot of smart people
say don't bet against l.a because you
got
sunshine and so there's reason why it's
way back
and my father said to me i said yeah
california i think l.a is going to be
it's not going to be it's down the pit
my father said yeah people have been
saying that since the 50s you know
i've been hearing that i've been hearing
that as long as i've been alive
don't like saying it's a popular thing
to do right like hate on that
hate on new york like it's the two
biggest badasses very it's a very
big diverse economy and oh by the way
it's always 75 and breezy that's
that's pretty cool you want to go to
mountain you want to go hiking you want
to go to the beach
what do you want to do and as far as the
homeless thing restaurant the federal
judge that just
ordered this the county of los angeles
the city of los angeles to do something
about their skid row
i mean oh [ __ ] i didn't know that
literally yeah they're in they're
something they're working on yeah but
were you were you really considering
moving b like i went to austin me and
chappelle touched down
and we were driving around and towards
the end trip i go chapelle could you
could you move out here he's like
he goes because you don't i don't think
so man where austin austin yeah i don't
think i could do it i
i love to if i were to ever this is fun
as [ __ ] though
i have a great time i love l.a but if i
was ever to leave it would be
i love to have a texas tattoo if i were
to go anywhere i would probably be
nashville because i spent more time
there but i wouldn't do now what people
don't realize i like dallas but people
don't realize about austin
is that it's small it's not a big it's
not as big a city as people think
it's cool and it's got great restaurants
it's got a young population there's a
lot of things
i think rogan's gonna you know he's
definitely put him on the map in the
county scene you gotta remember texas
was a big comic scene back in the day
and listen rogan could open up a [ __ ]
comic club and saudi arabia is gonna do
well
but that's joe rogan for these other
guys like you're not rogan dude
also rogan has been in l.a for 30 years
made his name here
for him to move out there and save
millions and millions on taxes makes all
the sense in the world
for you other guys who couldn't even
make in la he seems to be more
opportunities out there
maybe and i hope and i hope it works out
yeah it's just not it's not for me
and i do try i would send you houses my
dude i'm going i flew out there like a
house with my girl we went out there
tried to decide
and we touched on like i just it just
doesn't feel right like i feel like
the money i'd save on taxes i would lose
on
my shows because i want to have the same
guests i want the same vibes
there's a reason the same stuff the
reason l.a has been the the
sort of show business capital of the
world i gotta be honest i thought you
would move me
during all this i thought you would get
out there oh you're not going to work
my kids are here and my ex is here and
they're not in any rush to move anywhere
so my life is way more complicated you
know
maybe i would have maybe i i had a
fantasy of it you know this is tendency
when
covid and this state was shut down
homeless and all the other [ __ ]
you just kind of want to get away maybe
i would have but
there's also something about i think the
hardest thing about being
an artist or a comic let's just say for
us honestly
is um always staying
inspired to write new [ __ ] and i think
that requires a certain amount of
discomfort
a certain amount of some you got to push
back on something so i wrote an
hour a new hour for during covet
basically right
and i i saw it it's been a year it's
been a year yeah
no but i but i wrote an hour and i and i
and it was doing really well
and then i looked at it though i watched
it and i was like i'm gonna throw it all
away
you're sick of the covet [ __ ] right i'm
just gonna throw it away no it's not
just covert too it's also stuff that
where i was like it it works
and people laugh but that's a trick it's
not as good as i can do
sometimes that happens too i don't know
so so i don't even know where i'm going
with this but the
the point is that yeah you need that
fire it's what you're saying
i think you need uh i don't know i just
like it here
i just yeah i i i'm the same way man i
just love you would go to [ __ ]
you'd go to austin and nashville and
believe me that'd be a new set of
problems is what i'm saying
it's not there are a lot of people that
go to their money's not always the
answer you know
i know you're gonna save on money but
that sometimes like you're you're
trading one thing for another
it's gonna even out it's gonna even out
yeah and a lot of people that have gone
to
places like nashville and austin a lot
who go they regret it
yes i got buddies who regret it they
moved and they were me too
who are like i want to get back i think
yeah especially especially once we open
up yeah things are starting to open up
and yeah i mean i've been having a great
time here i mean
yeah granted the [ __ ] you know that we
all dealt with like
during the pandemic or whatever like
especially when it first started
starting yeah
he left for a little bit and then you
know now he's headed back
exactly what was that [ __ ] that david
lucas said um
about new york and l.a he said they're
just bad [ __ ] that are on the break
or something like that yeah
yeah like that's that which is a pretty
solid you know like yeah
that's great people are saying new york
is done and all that
and our buddy duff davidoff has a lot of
property in that area and doug was like
you're going to bet against new york
city really yeah you can bet against
them for a little while but
new york city i mean come on to your
point people have been saying this
forever ever forever
forever i will say though that are you
going to vote for caitlyn jenner
i will not be voting for caitlyn jenner
but i would like for new york
no i'm definitely not voting for you i'm
not voting for anybody who's a
left-wing operative because i think what
california what about balance
i agree what about uh would you vote for
that san diego mayor
i don't know i think he's running too
yeah i don't know enough about him i'll
vote for anybody who's pro-business and
has some sense that's caitlyn jenner
pro-business
she's like but she's like mini trump i
don't think caitlyn jenner is that
intelligent i mean all due respect
can you i'll wait but if you could tell
me caitlyn jenner
are killed she won a uh a woman i think
right or was it
by the way i don't know the way he
killed a human being yeah in her car but
um
that'd be fun but here's the thing
here's the thing about caitlyn jenner
she won a gold medal i think in 1976
and in 40 he won a goal he won a gold
medal in 1976 bruce generated
and in 40 years besides being married to
kris jenner who's very intelligent
and was a huge business she made a big
empire
whatever i i'm but i don't know what he
if you could
and i may be wrong but what has he
accomplished what has he done and what
has he
said that you think is different and
interesting or intelligent yeah
and then he did get he did get a sex
change and became a woman
which made news but is that i would call
this too i'm talking
years before the transition happened
years before brian goes oh bruce is
actually transitioned
and you said on rogan me and rogan tore
into you made fun of you for hours and
it was so much fun
we bullied you oh you already knew this
he knew because he had a [ __ ]
friend who was a mover and was like
painting the house or something i don't
know i just somebody who knows
the family and yeah and then i and then
year and then like
a few weeks after i'm at starbucks in
malibu and i see at the time
him and his hair was like long i'm
looking at his nails i'm like
what if callum's [ __ ] or not like
[ __ ] that's weird those are long nails
long nails
and then showing up like a bracelet and
then show enough
brian called it man i'm talking
five years before she transitioned damn
and we were like dude you're out of your
[ __ ] mind bruce
jenner what's wrong with you you'll see
i'm talking about five years i feel like
you're just saying something to say
something yeah
we wrote we lit his ass up i'll tell you
what i do want to do in the new studio
and i talked to rogan a little bit about
this i'm gonna do fight companions
all right i think we have the crew back
together yeah me and chin talked about
we're gonna have a whole area dedicated
to fight companions well let's let's
100 do that i love that idea
i love it that'd be fun right i'm kind
of thinking what do you think of this
idea i mean we'll talk about on the but
i kind of want because i know a lot of
fight experts and people i kind of want
to do something on a paid thing i don't
know whether it's rock fan or whatever i
don't know if patreon would let me
and i want to um i want to just take
boxing and mma
and i want to interview as many experts
as i can
and then i will and then have a food no
no no
i don't want to call it wrinkly diaries
i want to do i want to do i want to
read diaries no i want to do this and i
don't know if this is going to let him
get it out let him get it down
and i want to go who's the best to bet
on it'll be a betting channel
and i want to i'm going to i'm going to
recommend the most educated
you know based on where you're going to
get better son you're you ever
interviewed a better
not better so i want to get experts and
then i just say this is what the experts
say and here's why
but the experts are you talking about
experts like coaches and stuff you're
talking about like actual bettors
no uh coaches coaches and stuff like
that people who know the game that'd be
cool i did i don't know
it'd be an interesting idea because i
was like i wanna because you're pretty
good what your record betting was
yeah though the only time like you know
i have my deal with draftkings
last pay-per-view was the only one i've
lost but since i've signed the deal with
them i've gone i think five or five chin
or something like that you won all
like the parley five five out of six on
parlays wow
pretty impressive i mean it's all right
you you parlays you get like you know so
you gotta pick three fighters to win
and they boost the odds of the win so if
you bet a hundred you win three hundred
so what so all three have to win but
i'll throw like one dog in there but the
rest are heavy favorites like i picked
usman i forget who was like uspin
uh i forget i forgot to but i usually
take like few of the favorites and then
one dog rose was a surprise
yeah or no you always said she's the
best she's
monster rose i wouldn't say it was
surprised because she
she's a terrible match-up for uh wang
zaylie or uh
why is she a terrible match-up because
whaley's like it's kind of like uh
yuri vs um yan like like
whaley's very traditional and rose just
moves man
she's long and she's a nightmare for her
yeah nightmare yeah
but but to me is all here for rose if
she's here she's the best in the world
she's not you know she gets spiked on
her she's like she's like water man
that cake was insane oh front foot
roundhouse kick like a
straight up taekwondo front foot round
house kick right in the back of the jaw
like that you see your comments though
they vote red leave them dead or what
the [ __ ] you said
no yeah better off dead than red what
she's referring to you know obviously
being communist communist country old
school communist thing
that's an old-school american thing
better dead than red so that's what she
said but then
she got a bunch of flack for it because
obviously zhang
she's never say anything politically and
you can't should go missing if anything
so you're assuming
you're assuming that she is siding with
the government you can't because she'll
go missing
which is [ __ ] true why doesn't
anybody
why don't all these that's real [ __ ] but
why don't dude why don't these
why doesn't the woke community or just
the like the democratic party or
why don't they talk about how how
outrageous china is like what they're
well because
you only want to clean your house right
like you only saw your house so it's the
problems are over there
but rogan had a guy and his last name's
rogan as well and he worked as a
journalist in china
went dude it was you list that podcast
it will scare
the [ __ ] out of you he talks about how
these journalists like
spoke out just went missing or got put
into concentration camps dude i shot him
we're in prison i had to do a funk and i
had to do a retinal scan and i had to
have all my fingerprints remember when
you did that you're like brendan never
come here yeah
and then there's a thing you will not
you are not allowed to say anything
about the government
and you know they edit them so the the
phone and you know the version we get
here
like from the movies there's a different
version out there they edit it so like
let's say a chinese person gets kicked
in the face by someone from like
thailand or korea
how about this they edit reshoot it so
the chinese person will win
i was playing an agent an fbi agent who
had to arrest a chinese national
yeah and they go there's no way you're
putting that in the script you that
that's
so i had a whole chase team through
beijing through the old city of beijing
it was gonna be a nightmare because it
was the summer
i was have to run jump jump on a thing
they had a whole there was a whole thing
but i was going to do it right
and so i was like [ __ ] it's going to be
like that's going to be a long week of
shooting this thing
and they go it's not happening what do
you mean and they go
you won't be in chat as long as you
think because the the government will
not allow
an american to arrest a chinese person
on film
hey what about rush hour was america
right
yeah that was different america oh dude
you're saying this was filmed in
that's crazy huh oh it's crazy that's
insane or how about how about lebron
talking about you know equal rights and
with this this and it's like
but bubba you what about well you're not
going to talk about
china in the concentration camps and you
talking about human rights
what about this taking a lot of flak for
his oh dude he's completely
without that guy oh why because i don't
know what he's talking about why because
he carries a
book a malcolm x book to the arena and
one of the
journalists goes hey man uh what's your
what's your favorite chapter what's your
favorite thing about malcolm x in there
and they realize he's always on the
first page
you know he says he goes ah dude
interesting guy say that much no what
that was your takeaway yeah maybe not a
big reader well the cop shot that girl
from in the fall skirt she was stabbing
she was trying to kill another
like the black gal she was 16 year old
trying to kill another 16 year old girl
correct
and who was black and she was trying to
stab her correct kill her yeah and so
the cops and the cops shot
the black girls trying to kill the other
black girls yes but then they want to
avoid that cop but it was okay if the
black girl
kills the other black girl either way he
saved a black girl did you did you do
you have that
that white woman who's messing with that
mexican cop did you see that
oh i saw it like front headlights
oh you're not seeing this oh it's
beautiful please bring that up chin
please bring that up we know my
father-in-law is a cop and it's a
[ __ ]
nightmare watch how this woman treats
this was it a mexican woman
it was a white woman she's a college
professor apparently or a teacher
not anymore uh well i hope not because
she's an awful person
did you ever see the cop who did the
prank on lebron he and he got oh yes and
he got suspended it's so funny though
but you know but he got they made me 400
yes you are ma'am good morning which is
and the speed limit is 40 and i was
going 38
so why are you harassing you're correct
i pulled over because you're a murderer
oh yes you can't be on your cell phone
while you're driving oh and i was
recording you because you scared
me you can't use your cell phone while
you're recording you may have your
driver's license
i it's it's at my apartment
what's your apartment it's at my home
i'm just taking my sentence
do you have one do you have your
driver's license i if i mistakenly left
it at home do you have a picture of your
driver's license
yes i do may have it and can you call
your supervisor please
i already did he's on his way because
you're a murderer
and so you're giving me a cell phone
ticket is that why you're harassing me
not harassment i am enforcing the law i
have a right to
and record the police when they're
harassing me by all means
but you can't do it while you're driving
i would i can i wasn't
doesn't texting or none of that
going to murder me yeah well i'm sorry
you feel that way well you're
that's not just a feeling you're a
murderer you're good on that for me
thank you and i'm perfectly legal
and i'm a teacher so there
congratulations
they're threatening to kill me and my
son what the hell okay
don't tell you what you keep smiling
you're on camera
is this your car yes it is and you're
trying to say i stole my own car because
you're jealous
what the [ __ ] i'm so irritated right now
you away from me right here be hard not
to tase that [ __ ]
is your signature he's only citing you
for using your cell phone while you're
driving that's it there you go ma'am
science for him being a mexican racist
what is that name yes it's on the
citation man here you go mexican racist
what you're always going to be a mexican
you'll never be white you know
oh my god this woman she's white i hate
white people
there you go i don't think she's white
she's so [ __ ] she she's not black
that's a black woman no she's not white
man that's not one of us is
she's all you're a mexican racist he
goes that's black
she is she is a horrible human being
horrible and by the way that's not that
uncommon you just go
cops deal with it [ __ ] awful i do the
stories i hear it's insane and
that's why body cams are a good idea
because you capture
real [ __ ] in the world yeah most of
the time our weather kermit you got you
okay look this is west valley college
too damn
no it's where uh
[Music]
okay so bill and melinda gates are
officially going to
uh started getting a divorce they have a
a
separation agreement they don't have any
prenups
but they have an idea of how they want
70 billion should we get 70 billion
70 billion oh
speaking speaking of which a bunch of
people have been posting uh their dms to
bill gates saying like uh hey big head
with heart your boy mark harley
oh mark harley yeah he said hey big head
yeah with our eyes oh that's like a form
of flirting like negging like hey big
head
like what's up ugly that's the way that
somebody's like
weird yeah what's up you piece of [ __ ]
yeah hard eyes no
it means it actually means you're hot
what's up you're wart with eyes yeah
yeah
i don't like that it's the updated form
of nagging being mean to somebody and
trying to fly what's next
nagging that's what it is it's like a
backhanded compliment saying like oh
you're pretty for a big girl could she
have any better skin could cat have
better skin
that's why she's popping only fans
unbelievable it's my skin fans
yeah it's her skin i want to support you
but i can't go on that
let's not do that all right estimated
separate their estimated 130
well how much did jeff bezos wife get
because they didn't yeah she yeah she's
the richest woman in the world
she got a lot she's the richest woman in
the world and she's giving most her
money away
yeah but also when you have that
billions okay gotta yeah but also do it
yeah how many she couldn't spend that
money in
but now she's getting now uh mrs gates
is gonna be worth
i mean you're saying she's getting 70
billion
b i would imagine uh so it's yeah 38 35
billion dollars that's for uh jeff
bezos's wife
you know she she dates a science teacher
she also yeah she also has like a normal
yeah yeah do you see the science teacher
dm's what's up big [ __ ]
does she deserve 35 billion no she does
she started the company
yeah she helped him create money he'll
admit it no i don't know
melinda gates millennials no but but
his wife is smart as [ __ ] yeah no doubt
uh no no no she started the company you
know you know she would take the tape
and then do this on the box
hey man no she did help box up but she
was like no
i'm telling you but she's an intelligent
part of the company she ran a large part
of it in the beginning she really
when there were twenties now now now mrs
gates oh she's a computer programmer she
created
uh melinda gates was a lawyer ibm
i feel like she had a hand in microsoft
but not necessarily creating microsoft
the software engineer very [ __ ] you'd
have to be pretty smart to be with bill
gates yeah yeah
yeah yeah i don't think they're dating
bimbos no no
no jeff bezos got with that girl with
the though i mean like while they were
getting successful creating
their companies yeah i think now they're
definitely bumbling oh by the way
this is a hobby class uh introduced to
the apple two by her father and school
teacher she was a
manager yeah she's a beast yeah
she graduated valedictorian from
ursuline academy in dallas and you know
how good they are
earned uh bachelor's got her computer
science and economics from duke
university that's no joke yeah she's
smart as [ __ ]
no no and i'm not saying she's not smart
she probably helped out with the company
[ __ ] ah yeah i'm just so
big head smart okay that's small yeah
big head smart big hit smart
big head is rich as [ __ ] no big head's
gonna be the second richest woman in the
world
absolutely maybe the richest out you
depend on how that goes down sam tripoli
believes that
he lives in middle earth there i said
he's right and he'd be correct on that
i'd love something now to quote drake
you weren't with me shooting in the gym
you know now bill gates stayed up many
nights creating [ __ ] ibm right
many nights microsoft i'm not sure
microsoft yeah and she had no part of
that
well no because she's not a [ __ ]
computer software developer didn't say
something in there about her
in computer science right yeah but she
was married to him for 27 years she she
was part of the
foundation and stuff like that she did a
lot of stuff for them
you should be getting marketing manager
for with microsoft oh so was already
created okay cool
uh being responsible for the products oh
so it was already oh
cool yeah okay oh so he did all the work
okay oh she left microsoft that year and
reported focus on the family
oh okay just check it but she'll get
she'll get 70 billion that makes sense
that's stupid it's a lot of money
because that's super fair
as a guy dude if you make a mistake and
you're rich
and you got and you get married you dude
the law is not on your side
am i right
do you believe in prenups yes yeah but i
hear they don't work all the time
really that's what i've heard because
because i heard because one of my
buddies he he uh there
he is lawyers
yeah i didn't have one i would never
have done it in my case but
you get airtight pre-knows and they'll
do it because if you have a business and
other people are
employed it protects the business
there's there's pre-nups well the thing
with
yeah guys i know this is my buddy who
was the
divorce i'm just telling you
because she said she signed it out of
distress there's a lot
and so that's and that's how that makes
sense how he was able to house
that strategy would be to get you in
court so that you go
is it worth going through three years of
this that i'm gonna have to pay the
bills anyway it also depends like if
there's kids involved if me and my girl
ever broke up
dude i want her to have all that [ __ ]
take care of the kids
i'll live in a one bedroom apartment
yeah i'll be fine that's what kevin hart
did
with his uh first one yes yeah that's
500 that's how you should do it
yeah i mean when there's kids involved
it's like yeah they're more important
than you are
yeah they're bigger than you what else
you got jen
you're gonna make your girl sign a
prenup if you guys got married
no do you believe in marriage whoa
what's this tick-tock
we're going to make stevie signing
prenup i don't even know if i'm going to
get married but let's say you do yeah if
i do
let's go ahead like whoa yeah can
empire yeah um so ben affleck
is a single now he was dating that
really
really beautiful actress uh anna yeah
shoes and knives out
anyways he's on raya now he's on the
dating app and a
girl matched up with him but she
ultimately unmatched because she was
like
what are the chances that ben affleck is
trying to match with me on raya right
now this is probably somebody who
got through the system and is fake so
she unmatched with him
he went out of his way to dm her on
instagram saying hey why did you
unmatch with me it's me you posted it
and she posted it on tick tock
what a [ __ ] see him i would teach me
you should have said it's me batman go
down
he says it's me batman this is the video
okay
god girls will do anything for clout
her lips are natural naveen why did you
unmatch me
it's me oh that's batman dude it's
batman he's a stud
that's not i love ben affleck him and
jayla are hanging out again
yeah there we go that's that's what we
needed she's uh
she's uh into attention isn't she i feel
like a lot of people on tick tock
there's like a
group of people who get famous off of
she probably did your favorite bozo
she did him a favor she is impossibly
beautiful she's beautiful though
gorgeous
she's also all about herself boy yeah
she's out there yeah
okay makes them crazy yeah that's that's
crazy
that's expensive tail so t-pain
is really big on streaming video games
on twitch
and recently he was playing with a bunch
of people on call of duty there was
a random guy we don't know if it's like
a kid playing with him or just a random
dude who's trying to be [ __ ] up
started calling him the n word over and
over and over and he caught it on his
stream
he then proceeds to beat the guy who is
being racist against him there's a lot
of racism on there right
yeah a bunch it's video games it's kind
of like the one the way he
the way this all panned out yeah the way
he handled it was pretty funny
black lives matter
[Music]
i'm on every single one
keep talking that [ __ ]
[Music]
old yeah you're right you're right
maybe you saw he won the mass singer
yeah oh wow
you watched that do you you've never
seen it once
i never watched it once but i will i'll
go one way yeah go ahead check it out
it's good
t-pain is popping off on tick-tock
recently he made a video
talking about he didn't know the feature
on instagram where
in your dm requests it has in
chronological order then it has people
based off of how many followers they
have
will go to the top he didn't know that
there was that feature and he
accidentally ghosted a bunch of
celebrities for the past two years
didn't beyonce deal him yeah a bunch of
people dm'd him and he was like i didn't
know
that this was a feature he recently
uh linked up with jamie foxx to work on
something because of him
oh hell yeah yeah jb fox can sing oh he
could sing
everything dude he had an album
background i watched django last night
man
i was still somebody love django that's
one of my top favorite yeah
top five might be the best well i think
once i'm into hollywood but it might be
top-notch i haven't seen that one yet
you mean quentin tarantino's that
has to be top three has he ever made a
bad movie no no glorious bastards
oh i love him
reservoir dogs what i gotta check
reservoir dogs
kill late night talk shows so conan has
announced that his show is gonna come to
an end on june 24th
and it's really just because he's moving
over to hbo max he wants to be able to
get on a platform where he can speak
freely and speak to guests that he wants
to
so he's taking more of like a regular
podcast route rather than
late night show that's awesome yeah i've
been watching colorful sonic running
from 12 30 it did kill it did kill late
night didn't it it really did it it
because i think i am i have a theory on
that
because celebrities come on and they
just promote their movie nothing's real
i watched
i watched in 1990 1989
with tom cruise and it was right after
he'd done i don't know top gun or
something
and it would when he would go on he'd be
on for five minutes maybe last three
minutes four minutes whatever it was
and when you saw a movie star like that
it was such a mystery all of us were
like that's
a mystery that's a movie star what is it
like when we see like just a glimpse of
them
and that's why those pot those talk
shows were so huge because
like when you saw sylvester stallone you
were like in demolition man you're like
how is he that muscular he must be
eating so well
and not today no idea yeah
and now with podcasts with long-form
discussion all that
goes away and it's like there's but also
there's some of that like obviously
rogan with the vaccination talk and like
rome's like
i'm not [ __ ] doctor i just shoot from
the hip right that's why rogan's so big
because he's authentic yeah
but now you're like oh why doesn't you
know why doesn't ben affleck or why
doesn't leonardo dicaprio do more
interviews like oh because if he says
something that you don't agree with
you're not going to see his movie and
cancel yeah yeah so this woke left
you're scaring all you got from being
authentic of course but then you got
pioneers like rogan who are like no i'm
gonna i'm gonna stick with it part of it
is also actors don't have that much to
say
a lot of them don't a lot of them are
not that interesting after
some but some of them are like will
smith is a beast dude yeah
he's great on those yeah and those you
don't really do podcasts
no i'm talking about late night shows
yeah but they're all kind of lame like
they're all selling something like
they're over there
yeah you got a new album coming out i
went to a conan uh
taping and it was just yeah just the
interviews are just kind of do you
remember we did uh
the coco pop you remember we did that
like the after dark thing
no it was like we weren't on conan we're
but we're on their slideshow
no didn't wasn't that stern or was it
that was stern too yeah
yeah yeah our pr guy was like oh no we
booked stern i'm like holy [ __ ]
really where are they you're actually on
the after show with his crew
that talks recaps the show
i'm pretty sure y'all killed it though
you're on the show that talks about the
show
yeah that's when your name is very
strange yeah
but how howard stern i've listened to
him forever now because he's so
anti like he's so he's a germaphobe
he refuses to come to the city does the
podcast from his mansion and
he's like new york will never be back
out of touch
dude i'm out of touch like what happened
to the rebel we all [ __ ] used to love
man
that's so far gone that's what a lot of
money can do to you
yeah yeah take your edge off i love it
like a year ago
or maybe two years ago one of his guys
brought up rogan he goes that guy even
make money podcasting
and then he sees the rogue deal he's
like oh [ __ ] damn now howard still makes
more but still whose listen is serious
rental cars kind of your rental car it
was kind of a bust i feel like
serious radio yeah they still have
subscribers yeah i was going to say they
still have a bunch of them they don't
but it's but it's fake numbers because
when your rental car you get a car it
comes with it and they count
those as subscribers oh when's the last
time you're on the street and someone's
like dude you hear that howard stern
interview
the last time we listened to stern was
uh he and jay listen to us still when we
were in idaho yeah and uh the car we
rented it was playing
yeah all the rental cars says yes yeah
so they count all those rental cars as
subscribers
i mean seriously can't keep up
what else you got uh trailer fight club
the head said they're gonna they have
some vpns
of the illegal streamers right so they
can actually find out
they're saying that they can go through
vpns to get them for sure so they're
saying anyone who's illegally streamed
it to just
let us know and pay for it and then
we'll let go
right i bet it's about millions of
people yeah
but like like i know everyone's like oh
they're lying about their numbers i get
that but you know like all those young
kids that streamed it i bet it's two
three million streamed it so they can
get half of that you talk about 1.5
million
in pay-per-view buys the thing is that
but so
vpns they're saying they can go to the
actual vpn owners
to get the their ip addresses but vpns
they're the reason why people buy them
is that
you don't know your actual ip address it
scrambles it up right
so that's where it gets tricky you don't
have to be like a court battle
i don't quite believe this yeah they're
trying to scare them exactly
because i thought that's what i thought
the vpn like protects you exactly that's
what the whole world the government did
that was
people hiding money in switzerland and
they said to all these wealthy people
they said
the the swiss government they said we
worked out a deal with the swiss
government
and we are going to open they're going
to let us in
to see i think it was like 25
of all the accounts they have they're
just [ __ ] and they said
if you tell us now and pay your taxes
you'll be fine
if you're one in four if you're unlucky
and you want to roll that dice
and you come up with a one you know and
or you know you're [ __ ]
yeah you have a 25 chance of losing
everything and going to jail
up to you if you're a gambler i know
right yeah
i'd rather be terrified
they're probably calling their bluff
yeah get right in here you move that
[ __ ] somewhere else or you're like hey
you guys what's also with dana remember
he's like we're coming after you i can't
wait to catch it like nothing that you
don't hear about afterwards
like no we caught a guy oh man i can't
wait he's doing bad
like well what's his name ryan yeah
oh man i don't believe you he's doing
bad yeah he dude
he's doing bad you got 10 years in
prison you'll be doing
bad yeah i ran i tried to threaten my
son but i realized i wasn't going to do
anything because he got me so mad i'm
like let me tell you what i'm gonna let
me tell you what's gonna happen if you
do that again let me tell you what
happened
it's gonna be bad yeah i can't have a
punch
i don't know what to say what else you
got jen
uh so someone sent this to me a fan and
i just forgot their name but it was just
a funny ad that someone put on
craigslist for this pontiac fiero
that's hilarious and then if you look at
the actual description
do i want to be a cocaine feel grit gold
they locked sex got taken straight from
the beach to miami
the answer is yes this guy is awesome
do not read this post without a fire
scene i love this guy
i would love 86 fiero gt v6 four speed
for sale reason by this car
impress your friends depress your family
it's not space
30 kilos space kilos not included front
space 60 kilos
engine in the middle like a ferrari but
better
steel cape heads girl run quail to the
mountains of beverly hills or oakland
reasons not to buy this car you can't
handle the heat
you like ferraris too many letters
cylinders here are somewhere
more efficient the last image in this
post offends you in any way
you don't like driving the only v6 usdm
midship to hit the states
you don't like people asking you tons of
dumb questions like you do rudimentary
tasks including
but not limited to hey man where's the
engine have you got some miami
why did you buy this if they ask this
they're not cool enough for you if
they're your friends or your family just
let them go the fiero's
all that matters now why why memes aside
this is a three owner gt
i love this guy i think he's legit yeah
i'd vote for that guy
if i was like i just buy all that i just
buy it he's in cali oh it's four grand
oh he's in santa cruz i might just buy
that car
yeah it does look pretty cool right
right there in the night time yeah
this is cool yeah it's cool only four
g's that's hilarious
i think vince vaughn at the height of
his powers drove a cutlass
like a like an old cutlass around town
just didn't give a [ __ ]
he's the best
uh just one more it's just this news
anchor who
for some reason she was found naked in
her car on her
on her own in like a regular like
cul-de-sac or something like that
she's a bad she's not bad yeah she's a
baddie this chick
oh damn yeah she's so hot and this is
her instagram
and did she get in trouble she didn't
get in trouble
she just actually went on the news and
said she you know something happened i
i'll take responsibility for my actions
she's in vegas right i think so yeah
well she's well she's
she's smoking her yeah i mean
what is her nationality it said east uh
eastern african
painfully hot oh she's probably she's
east africa
he's having a mean ethiopian eritrean
somali oh my god
oh she's in jesus christ yeah that's
that's a big problem
she could be from zanzibar zanzibar i
think she's coming off tanzania i think
she's from heaven what famous singer was
from zanzibar oh hold on uh
you know yeah i know the lead singer
queen that's right freddie mercury thank
you oh wow
i didn't know that yes you know she's
well
she's impossible and did she get
arrested for being naked why was she
naked you know what i say when she takes
her shirt off and i'm about to make love
to her i go your breasts are impossible
now check this impossible thing out they
did arrest her
but uh i it's like reckless driving
because she wouldn't do a sobriety
test so you can refuse to do the test
oh god man i mean if you're a cop go
enjoy the rest of your night dude you
got a gift you ask me
well huh they look real
yeah real fake but i don't care
man that's incredible no congratulations
yeah the cop when she was naked he must
have been like whoa what cupcake what
kind of prick
i bet is female cops because what what
male cop would give or take it
i mean no i've been like wow this is
thank you just going to sleep just
have a good night let her sleep you
sleep naked have a good night
something else now that's a filter but
she's still yeah i don't care she is
she's definitely
dude could there be a easier gig doing
the weather in vegas
it's gonna be hot i think it's
gonna be real hot today it's gonna be
hotter tomorrow yeah
she's amazing congratulations on
everything oh
chunky go back go back because i like
that that's that's like the chunky
friend that's one of the other ones like
both
this one here you like that no not my
thing but some guys step up yeah sure
i'm a little light and he asked for that
as we know you chappelle
what do you think i like that no i don't
know i don't know
that's good yeah she's she's awesome
they're all too dark jackets
all right
i love this yeah gorgeous yeah dude
she's a [ __ ] she's a
la-10 l10 we just don't give those out
here
no well buddy we did it again we did it
again buddy oops i
did it again come see me and i played
tucson at the rock
one show tomorrow night wednesday at the
rock
oh you're welcome you're wednesday
through sunday dad well i'm there in
tucson then i drive over to phoenix
tv live thursday through sunday i'm
doing a sunday show two shows saturday
shows right
one show thursday get your tickets tampa
florida improv may 21
22. vegan hungry podcast live may 19th
in zany's jesus christ
i'm busy you're on the road now don't
get excited i'm in toledo at the funny
bone may twenty years
are you gonna stay at my hotel san
antonio make a call yes
i'm staying at san antonio do lol june
third
fourth and fifth get your tickets
staying at our favorite hotel yes
but tucson tomorrow tucson at the rock
tomorrow and cb live this weekend come
see me and
this weekend i'm lexington kentucky they
opened up even more
covent beat it nerd they opened up more
so the shows aren't sold out so now
there's tickets available for saturday
friday and thursday that's this thursday
friday saturday then houston texas may
20 through the 22nd
that will be me chappelle and david
[ __ ] lucas who will be on the
podcast tomorrow
that's savage that's in houston texas uh
houston improv may 20th 22nd then
oklahoma city bricktown comedy club
june 10th through the 12th get your
tickets at fatkz.com
also for thick boy we are doing a
special cinco de mayo sale
uh five percent off for may 5th may the
fifth be with you
everybody guys may 5th
uh cinco de mayo 5 off the entire
website at thickboy.com that's for cinco
de mayo only this is we need to start
stick boy
this this weekend i'll be in philly at
the helium
comedy club may 638 five shows and then
the following weekend may 13th through
the 15th
i'll be in raleigh north carolina at
good night's comments
headlining i love this ticket lacey.com
you listen you are do you remember what
you said to me when i first
met you no you gave me a guest spot in
phoenix arizona do you remember what you
said to him
you said stop doing comedy and now
you said no you will never make it hey
he did it you gave me a guest spot
because i worked at the hotel i let you
valet for free
hooked him up right yep yeah and then
you said he didn't tip
he did not but you know what i don't
know you know you did you did you did no
he did
no he did really good he did really good
uh and
right when i got off stage you said get
out of arizona
you said move to l.a yeah because you
had i could see it and then here we are
today yeah you have
i'm gonna tell you this you have you are
a classic example of how you
were successful you have an amazing
attitude you're a great
guy and you work your ass off and you
take nothing for granted
and you are the blueprint for anyone who
wants to
like make it cause you're undeniable but
you call me he goes i love chappelle
i remember you said that but but of
anyone that could have any excuses of
not to make it it's this [ __ ] guy
yeah i know
it's the gap you know it's not that
sullivan and his stepdad will be opening
up the shows
my stepdad's performing with me we
rekindled
[Laughter]
oh he must be so proud of you man oh
dude yeah it's insane it's only going to
get better
yeah no yeah chappelle's just getting
started i appreciate you guys man i bet
by next year he's my
i can't go on the road with you anymore
it makes me happy he's like that's what
that's that's yeah my boy louise alvarez
who opens for me you know yeah i love
louis
and luisa shouts out to louise he works
so hard and he's always writing and he's
great
and i say to him i said i said your job
is to look at me and go hey bry
i can't feature for you anymore because
i'm headline and you should
remember when we were on the road
together for like three months and then
i just [ __ ] spread my wings and
started doing my own [ __ ]
stop doing that yeah you didn't do that
really big ass wings
that's how you
fun fact about uh luis and i um
our dads were both in rival gangs oh
[ __ ]
yeah is that right well in fact his dad
fired at louise's dad
i don't know they might go that far i
like it yeah they were in rival gangs
right
yeah well tell luis if we see him keep
that same energy
yeah no he's opening for me yeah and
louis
he skates too he's a really good skater
is he really yeah he can
he plays guitar and he's like he's going
to get any more mexican if you're over
if you're if you can still
shave you shouldn't own a skateboard but
that's my opinion i'm kind of online i
mean unless
you paid a lot of money unless you're on
the cover of thrasher don't get your
skateboard i'll
be on the cover of thrasher that boat
has sailed my man
you know this is too big for
skateboarding too big for a skateboard
besides do you see me skate he can skate
but also but but also who who what 30
year old's been on thrasher
if your name's not tony hawk there's 30
year olds on thrasher first of all tony
hawk's not in his 30s anymore that's
what i'm saying
when he's 30 i bet he was on there bro
there's a lot of 30 year old men on
thrasher rob deredick
no he's older i know that's what i'm
saying yeah
but he but rob dyrdek's in a different
lane now yeah we're talking about we're
talking about
you know you can board how many 30 year
olds are on the cover of ufc magazine
none why because they're old
all right all right so well that's it
guys
kentucky see you soon see you philly see
you this weekend